interesting media story for you I like
doing these media stories megyn kelly
has had an interesting 12 to 18 months
she used to be at Fox News she was at
the center of this sort of faceoff with
Donald Trump during the Republican
primary debates there was that incident
where Donald Trump said that megyn kelly
was bleeding out of her you know where
she then later came out and said that
Roger Ailes also harassed her she was
slammed by some people for coming out
only when many other women had already
gone public against Roger Ailes and
arguing that she did it in the safest
possible way
anyway she ultimately left Fox News big
announcement that megyn kelly was
launching a new show on NBC News okay
interesting well we'll see what the show
is what the format is we'll see how that
goes was my thought at the time she was
going to have a Sunday night show as
well as a daytime show okay the Sunday
night show has been an absolute and
total disaster the idea was it's gonna
be huge guests major ratings blockbuster
interviews her first show she
interviewed Vladimir Putin and genuinely
it was pretty interesting I actually
actually thought it was it was quite
good second show Alex Jones conspiracy
theorists from Infowars Alex Jones was
megyn kelly second guest millions of
dollars months of preparation and lead
up and Megyn Kelly's big score is Alex
Jones who sells male vitality
supplements on his website already kind
of a bad omen but okay that's the
nighttime show what about the morning
show Megyn Kelly's morning show
premiered last week it has been a total
unmitigated embarrassing disaster and
NBC is now panicking about it megyn
kelly during her first few episodes
asked Will & Grace fans if the show
turned them gay she awkwardly asked Jane
Fonda about her plastic surgery in what
was really a very strange way to just a
weird way to do it a cameraman
accidentally stepped in front of Megan
Kelley's interview with a soccer star
and said the S bomb on the air
the rankings have been terrible now I
don't blame megyn kelly that much here I
really mostly blame NBC who at NBC News
thought that this was really gonna be a
good idea
her whole shtick was she's the tough
interviewer on Fox News
she's not gonna let people get away with
whatever it is I guess that they might
try to get away with how does that play
on morning TV not that well kind of
reminds me of the Peter Principle I've
spoken about this before the Peter
Principle arguably applies to Donald
Trump as well in fact it should probably
be renamed the Donald principle and the
idea is people get promoted to their
level of incompetence so fast food is my
favorite example you get fired you get
hired rather I'm skipping ahead a few
steps to the firing you get hired as a
fry cook at a fast food place and you do
incredibly well you put the fries in the
fryer really precisely there's no
spillage of oil you take the fries off
at the right time you show up to work on
time you're great as a fry cook so you
get promoted to cashier cashier all
right little more complex takes you a
little while to learn the computer
system for taking orders but you learn
it you're still reliable that's in your
nature the computer system wasn't that
complex so you become the best cashier
at whatever fat fast food food place
we're imagining well listen they're
looking for good people to become shift
supervisors and you excelled at being
the fry cook you killed it at being a
cashier so you are the natural choice to
be promoted to shift supervisor now as
shift supervisor you're still reliable
you still show up on time and you try
really hard turns out though you're not
really that good at managing other
people you're really bad at setting
limits with staff you've been promoted
above your skills and abilities because
you were so good at the lower positions
and you've been promoted to the point
that you're no longer good at your job
that's the Peter Principle and that's
kind of the idea with megyn kelly here
she was hired to do legal segments on
special report with Brit Hume and
weekend live on Fox News
then she started appearing on O'Reilly
she did well people liked her she filled
in for Greta Van Susteren show okay she
did well so she got herself an afternoon
show on
FoxNews then she got the nighttime show
on Fox News well she did so well that
NBC said let's give her a half-hour news
magazine program as well as a daytime
show because she's so great and it turns
out she's actually not a good fit for
those people aren't liking her the
ratings are in the tank it is the Peter
Principle personified and we'll see what
ultimately happens I don't know that Fox
News it's gonna fire her anytime soon
they paid her a lot of money she'd have
to get that money she'd be entitled to
that money no matter what because of the
contract she has with NBC News so I'm
thinking that NBC News is going to stick
with it until they're a hundred percent
sure that it's not going to work but
just a total embarrassing scandalous
media implosion and I I actually don't
know anyone who has seen any of this new
morning program I just I read some
articles about it and watch clips online
but I don't know of anyone who's
actually watched it if you if you've sat
through an entire episode of this thing
let me know I'd be curious to hear what
you think the video you just watched was
made possible by support from you please
go to patreon.com slash david pakman
show you can make a pledge of as little
as $1 per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad